i say start small start small
dip your toe in the water see how it
works get a feel for it so why are
people
not investing they're scared disciplined
scared evan no they're scared but it
troubles me immensely now to realize
that there's a hundred million people in
america
that don't invest
[Music]
i want them to see the master elevator
pitch man
tell us what beanstalks is and why we
should care
well beanstalks helps you make the most
important decision of your life
investing for your future
i realized going through this whole
coven pandemic thing
so many of my employees haven't saved
any money at all and there's a big
difference between
saving and investing the whole idea is
you take
some number each week and you put it to
work as an investment
you do it when you're young and keep
doing it throughout your whole life so
when you retire when you're 65 or so
you've got some serious money in the
bank we know from the past 50 years
that the market returns are kind of six
to eight percent over long periods of
time
now what i'm shocked about is so many of
my employees and the companies that i
work with
nobody's saving anything they're not
even investing or saving so i wanted to
change that
in order to do it i didn't want to make
it complicated you had to buy and sell
stocks and bonds so many people don't
want to do that or don't know how to do
it
being stocks makes investing really
simple
you attach it to your bank account you
decide i suggest a hundred bucks a week
most people can do that
evan you know that and then it puts it
to work in a series of very diversified
exchange-traded funds
and those are built so that you can
build a very diverse portfolio that just
goes to work for you
week after week after week after week
you can automate the hundred dollar
transfer or you can decide
what what and how much you want to do it
doesn't matter but i try to make it
really simple because you gotta start
now now now now because if you do a
hundred bucks a week and you're only
making
you know 52 58 000 a year the average
american salary
you'll end up with hopefully if the
markets do what they do
in the last 50 years you'll end up with
something like a million five in the
bank and that's what you can live off
over the years you've given so many
different investing
principles maxims from never put more
than 20
into equity than the gold or you know
the advice from your mom who spent a
third of her paycheck you're talking
about 100 bucks a month your mom put
a third of her paycheck into bail bonds
for 40 years
in ideas like only spending interest on
the principal only by dividend stocks
how much of the kevin o'leary strategy
for investing is rolled into bean stocks
or are you just giving it up to the ai
to take care of it no
no i i have a philosophy about
conservative investing
and if you look at what's inside of bean
stocks
it's reflected in that obviously you
know i've been an investor in bean
stocks and helped fund it because i
couldn't find anything like it
but there's very conservative portfolios
of companies with strong balance sheets
to pay dividends
in many cases and that matters because
when you're investing you want the power
of strong balance sheets because they're
the ones that don't necessarily
collapse in a recession or a downturn
like we just went through
but at the same time you want the
compound and investing of dividends in a
long-term strategy that's what my mother
taught me
you know if if i could have turned my
mother into an investment strategy she
would have been called beanstalks
that's what would have happened and
that's the way i look at it and i'm
really proud of the platform i
i tell everybody i talk to now all the
millennials i work with
download it check it out look at it it's
free to download have a look at it
and it's very very simple try it and see
if you can get into the discipline it
provides
of putting something aside each week
that was another one of my mother's
edicts
she did a third of his paycheck you
mentioned that evan that's a lot for
people
if you can just do 10 that's spectacular
if you could just do 10
but this idea of investing a little bit
in yourself
there's always something every week some
piece of crap you don't have to buy that
you don't need that you're going to
throw out in six months
why do that ask yourself imagine i'm on
your shoulder every day
looking at you as you're picking
something up you're about to buy another
pair of sneakers saying
don't do that don't do that invest in
your future
that's what beanstalks is for i love it
so why are people
not investing they're scared disciplined
scared evan no they're scared they hear
all these you know slick terms you got
to be a stock picker
you know there's a lot of people that
want to try and do that i'm okay with
that
but if you really want to invest that's
not day trading and and
you need to understand that when you're
investing you're trying to find
positions you're going to buy and hold
on to over a long period of time
and so you know they don't some people
get intimidated saying well i don't know
how to buy stocks and bonds i don't want
to set up an account for that
that's why i develop bean stocks to make
it super simple i mean
basically you download it you tell it
tell a little bit about yourself you
link it to your bank account you tell it
what to take out and put into your
investment account
and it's a great way even to save cash
because it gives you an interest rate on
that it's a
savings vehicle but more importantly
it's an
investing vehicle and people
i say start small start small dip your
toe in the water
see how it works get a feel for it put a
few hundred dollars in and then
understand what's going on and then
invest for the long term that's what
bean socks is all about
and is it just five bucks a month for
the whole thing
yeah i wanted to make it real easy you
know i talked to so many people about it
and there's all kinds of different
schemes and costs and
fees i said screw all that make it
really transparent and easy no matter
how much you invest it stays at five
bucks a month
that's how it works that's how we're
starting it that's how i foresee a
future looks
and i think people want that they
appreciate the transparency they see
okay one price one fee and i could put
in 200 bucks a month i could put in a
thousand a month i can put 500 whatever
it is
get to work start investing look you
know i i've been
i live in the financial services
industry and i realize we
do very complex stuff with bonds and
stocks and private equity and hedge
funds and all that
but that's not the average person they
don't want to do that they just want to
find a way to safely invest
and do it in a way that they can
understand is transparent and makes it
easy that's the key simple investing
that's the theme of being sucks that
what i think i've achieved that evan i
think people just have a look at it
so i guess for people is this only for
someone who's purely starting up who
hasn't ever invested in something or are
you
ultimately looking to replace financial
advisors
no no i never want to replace financial
advisors but when you're starting out
and you're only putting a few hundred
dollars to work
you know a week there's not a whole lot
of financial advisors that are
interested in you they want to get to
you when you've got a quarter of a
million or more
and that's a good thing there's nothing
wrong with financial advisor i support
them in a lot of my businesses
because i'm involved in financial
services industry i'm worried about the
people
that are really starting or don't
understand in
investing regardless of how much money
they want to put aside
this is a platform that you know lets
you use the device that you know very
very well
your phone and download an app go to the
app store download it have a look at it
you don't have to be embarrassed about
it you don't have to be confused it's
all laid out
it's for them and it doesn't matter you
know that
you're not sophisticated as an investor
what matters is it's simple
and it's diversified and that's an
important aspect of investing
diversification
we do that by using exchange-traded
funds we think we've got the right ones
we think we give you conservative goods
good companies that you know provide
returns over long periods of time
that's the essence of it how did you
meet the co-founder
well i've had this problem i've been
starting about four years ago
when shark tank started doing tours of
high schools
we've been all over the country and you
know it was in my mind but then
when i started to see what was going on
last year with my own employees
and of supply chains that work with my
over 50 companies
i was amazed practically none of them
have savings or investments
and i'm saying you know they're young
people they're in their 20s i'm saying
guys this ain't gonna work that you've
got to start
taking care of yourself you've got to
start planning for yourself no one's
going to be there when you're 65
you're going to be there when you're 65.
you've got to make sure you've taken
care of your future
and that's when i got on the the
beanstalks bandwagon i talked to connor
the co-founder said connor listen i'm
dealing with people every day
you gotta make it easy forget about
these sophisticated trading platforms
they exist already there's nothing wrong
with it if people want to try and buy
and sell stocks like a day trader
that's fine but that's not what i'm
talking about here i'm talking about
helping people
invest for the long term this is not a
day trading platform this is a way
to put 100 bucks to work a week minimum
that's what i recommend
and let it grow and just watch how it
works and i've made it
i think it's i haven't found one easier
so to me it's
it's the best platform to keep it easy
and i think of uh all the people in the
financial sector
you do if not the best one of the best
jobs of just making complex things
feel easy because it's overwhelming it's
stressful people don't want to make a
mistake
yeah i built this for my kids i mean you
know they're in the same boat all
of these others are and i you know i
showed it to them and said what do you
think
and the whole idea was
can you make it so that i can set it up
in 20 minutes
because i'm busy doing my own thing i'm
in college or in school whatever it is
make it easy make it like everything
else i do i do it on my phone
you know a lot of people don't even use
laptops anymore so this is a mobile
app you can download and i kind of use
them
and their friends as sort of a guide to
see as we develop the features
and all they wanted was make it easier
make it easier make it easier make it
easier make it easier
we worked on it for over a year and i
think we brought a fantastic app to the
market
and believe me it's easy someone's
asking is the app global
well it's global in the sense you're
going to own stocks from all around the
world because we have diversification
but we're focused primarily on american
large cap stocks in the portfolios
and you can see they're very transparent
you can see the etfs
and decide what you want to do it
actually sets you up but i believe you
should have exposure to other markets
too
but most people want to be domestic and
the majority of the stocks are domestic
but they're really high quality evan
that's what matters you want good
companies you don't want speculative
not when you're investing i get it when
people want to day trade stuff
that's fine and many people do but this
is investing it's different
someone's also asking what's the
difference between this and a mutual
fund
well a mutual fund um you know is
something that i don't use anymore i'm
not saying they're bad
but i prefer the transparency and the
tax efficiencies
of exchange traded funds we don't use
mutual funds inside bean stocks
because we don't like them as much as
exchange traded funds you can see what
you own in
an exchange traded fund it's very very
tax efficient you don't get big surprise
tax bills at the end of the season
i haven't owned a mutual fund in years
and years and years to me it's my
opinion
they're old school they're in the old
days the new trend is to get the
efficiencies etfs provide and that's
what's inside
of beanstalks etfs and i think they're
the fastest growing if you
look at the growth of of where money
goes to invest in sectors
it's in exchange-traded funds it's a
very very efficient transparent way to
invest
and again if you don't understand what a
mutual fund is versus an etf
we do that for you inside of beanstalk
so try and make it really simple
so if i go and sign up am i then asked a
bunch of questions based off age
asset allocation like how does it then
decide where to put my money you know
you don't even have to do that if you
don't want to
i mean if you say you want to you know
save into cash
x amount and the rest you want to invest
it'll do that for you but we've made it
even simpler than that it basically asks
you know who you are
what your objective is what you'd like
to do over time
those are reasonable questions to ask
but again we've made it incredibly
simple you don't have to sit there and
say well i want a sectoral allocation of
this percent for this sector
that percent for this sector it's
inherent
in what we've done inside of beanstalks
we've given you lots of diversification
we've given you an opportunity to be an
investor in the markets
in a way that i think i can't think of
an easier way to do it
but again the best way to get a feel for
it and then simply download it look at
it
it's free to download check it out i
think we've done an
amazing job in setting the steps up and
it won't take you very long maybe 20
minutes to get set up
and then put your first hundred dollars
to work and
stay at it and remember i want to be on
your shoulder saying don't buy that
piece of crap
invest it in your future instead i love
it you need to have a little
uh augmented reality kevin o'leary
i should sell that like a bobble head
that says yeah in your future investing
yeah yeah i love it that's what i should
be doing how did you guys come with the
name
you know there's the idea of growth
there's an old jack and the beanstalks
adage and i thought it was really cute
and a lot of people remember it when
their mothers used to read them that
story when they were young
and it's sort of a social media and the
way we spelt it bea and sdox kind of get
made reference to stocks and indexes
it was cute people liked it i mean
you're looking for a name that people
can remember
jack and the beanstalks is easy to
remember and and so far the feedback's
been fantastic and that's what i like i
love
hearing from people that try it i mean
you know
spend a lot of time and money to set it
up proud of that but
this is part of my whole financial
literacy platform when i run around
high schools now where i talk to kids
and you know hopefully we're going to
have a much more buoyant program next
year
obviously covets slowed things down but
people's interest in investing hasn't
changed
that's why the markets continue to do so
well there's a real focus on the markets
now
and this is a way for you to get
involved if you're thinking about long
term
you seem to have taken a lot more of an
active role
in this business compared to the other
investments that you've made not that
you're not active but
this one seems to be extra important to
you
is that true and and how come yeah
you're right it's a good observation
you're making there evan it is i spent a
fair
part of my week promoting it and trying
to get it
you know in people's hands i i my mother
taught me something once called karma
she said if you've been successful in
life you have to
pay it back or pass it forward and
and i do that with a lot of my
entrepreneurs and i've got a portfolio
of over 50 companies now and i spent
time with them too
but it troubles me immensely now to
realize
that there's a hundred million people in
america
that don't invest a hundred million
like that's a huge number and
you have to ask yourself why what
happened did we fail them in financial
literacy did we not teach them
we teach them everything else in high
school and you know geography sex
education
math reading skills and we don't talk to
them about investing
that's wrong so that's it's kind of one
of my
you know missions i guess you would call
it and any chance i get like talking
with you here today to talk about
beanstalks
and really what the underlying motive is
i'm
very happy to do that i really am i i
just feel
it's important and i and i think
i would if at the end of this and a few
years from now
we had a whole bunch of people saving
and investing
that would be a great outcome for me and
the easier i can make it for them the
better
it's just one of those things that's
beyond just um
a single company it's kind of a mission
statement
i love it now i saw you run start engine
as well
raising capital for investors are you
still looking for investors as well for
this business yeah i mean you know
i'm a big believer in equity
crowdfunding um it's a new form of
financing not just for bean stocks for
all my companies
i mean it competes with um vegetarian
capitalists that competes with private
equity it competes with hedge funds
i just think at times like this you know
if you go back to 2007 2008
indiegogo and kickstarter emerged from
financial crisis
as a as a class as a way to get
entrepreneurs going and now today
with equity crowdfunding it's a new
class of financing
with the one thing that a venture
capitalist can't do for you
it lets your customers of your product
or service
be investors in the same which is really
really interesting and
and so i'm a supporter of all that you
can learn a lot more about it it's just
going to start engine.com
but i think that whole chain that whole
shift
to equity crowdfunding is one of the
great things that have come out of the
stress we've
gone through in this whole in this
latest pandemic
related you know financial crisis if you
want to call it that
the hundred dollars a week target
how did you get to that number like why
is that the magic number you're
recommending for people
well again evan i wanted to keep it
simple everything's about simplicity
people can remember the name beanstalks
they can remember a hundred dollars a
week
they can remember you know thinking
about getting over a million dollars by
the time they retire
very simple themes i think are what are
needed here
i mean you really if you make the
average salary of 52 to 58
000 a a year in u.s you know
you think about the global market that's
one of the highest incomes in the world
but still that's the
average 52 000 you can put aside
a hundred dollars a week there's
something you're doing during the week
you don't need to
to save that crisp 100 and put it into
your future i mean i found
the reason i said 100 i feel everybody
can do it i challenge my own kids to do
it you know
it means when your grandmother gives you
a birthday gift and a card
and you know maybe it's 50 bucks 20
bucks whatever it is
save it for yourself that's the whole
idea of beanstalks
is there an age limit can i do this for
my 11 year old son
i think you have to wait till you're 18.
it's kind of important
the minute you open a bank account you
should be doing this that's the way i
look at it so you could
i think you do a great gift to your
child if you started talking to them
about investing
and you know when they open their own
their own bank account savings account
you link them up with a way to start
investing remember i keep saying
saving is different than investing
when you you save cash you make a
nominal interest rate right now it's
very
very very low because rates are close to
zero but when you invest you're
investing in america's future and it's
companies that
create products and services that people
buy everybody knows
apple for example everybody knows
microsoft those are the kind of
companies you may want to own
because you use their products every day
and they pay dividends
and those are the kind of companies that
we have inside of beanstalk so
that's the kind of investing you'll be
doing if you decide to put a hundred
dollars or more aside a week and
start building your portfolio what would
you tell entrepreneurs a lot of my
audiences entrepreneurs
um some of them have made and had a lot
of success a lot of them are in the
early stage of just trying to figure
things out
and they're pouring everything they have
into their business
and they might be saying kevin i don't
know it's hard to think about the future
when i'm trying to make my business fly
what advice would you tell them you know
what
advice i tell them is you can save a
hundred dollars even if you're working
25
hours a week or a day i mean i all my
entrepreneurs work all day only
but but i also encourage them look get
some diversification in your own
portfolio
you basically got all of your eggs in
one basket your business
but there's nothing wrong with just
finding a hundred dollars you can save a
week because everybody can
and put it aside and invest it in a
broad range of companies that we have
through those etfs i talked about
earlier that are completely different
than the company that you're working on
and that it's something that you're
putting aside regardless of the outcome
of your entrepreneurial journey as you
know evan sometimes it doesn't work out
sometimes you have to try two or three
times
but investing is long term and it puts
aside something that you don't have in
your business which is
very very concentrated it gives you
something called diversity and i like
that a lot in investing
someone in the chat was asking they're
in debt right now
should they get out of debt first and
then start this or should they start
right now
well there's different kinds of debt if
they're in credit card debt they really
should get rid of that first because
they're paying somewhere between 18 and
21 interest which is brutal
but you know if it's a mortgage that's
different if you have a mortgage that's
about
your assets your home and i would say
that you want to
invest beside that as well you want to
start diversifying
so i don't i think getting rid of credit
card debt first then investing in being
stocks is a good idea
but if you're already in a mortgage you
have a car loan that you're already able
to support
you should at the same time be putting
100 bucks a week into your future in a
diversified portfolio
and and for financial education for
america if you could
make one change if you if you were made
president and you can come in and make
one change
across america for financial education
what would you recommend
happening i would adopt what florida's
doing right now you know i have a home
in miami and i've gone to high schools
in florida and talked to teachers and
principals there
they are making it mandatory within you
know grade school and
in high school at least in high school
to to actually have financial literacy
learn about credit card debt learn about
investing learn about the concepts of
this
in the curriculum it's so important they
are the leader you think about the
educational system in america new york
florida
texas and california they're the
majority of our schools we have about
110
000 schools why do i know that because i
used to sell them software for reading
and math
with the learning company and i dealt
with almost all of them but we at that
time
had nothing to do with financial
literacy and i regret that immensely
when i had that opportunity when i was
the largest purveyor of educational
software in america
i should have got that going then it's
my mistake and i'm trying to make up for
lost time
doing bean stocks now that's crazy how
long you've been in the education
business i just realized that
yeah yeah i mean i know that's just an
inside out 110
000 buildings the whole way it works but
florida's done it right
they're really really saying we can't go
on any longer leaving people
many people only get a high school
education there's nothing wrong with
some of the wealthiest people in america
only graduate high school
but we got to teach you that you have to
understand what debt is and what
investing is we have to do that
florida recognizes that hopefully that
will be adopted
into new york and then texas and
california and then when you get those
states as i learned
in the in the days of the learning
company you get everybody else
because they kind of follow one of those
jurisdictions or another but that's the
majority of schools in those four states
and i think you know getting out there
with the beanstalks message and getting
people to try it and
try investing is very important for me
if you like that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe